yeah well if they at the beginning with
leonidas yeah that too which is like the
way of getting like an action set piece
out of the way but then it's like okay
now we actually get to the story I feel
like they were when they were making it
they were like okay so how soon do we
have to throw in the 300 thing yes okay
it's all going on okay everyone carry on
with your lives
put all the sons put on at all times
I'm a big Assassin's Creed fan like
played pretty much every single one
sorry rogue get around to you one day
but like story wise I would say Odyssey
God if I call it origin though so sorry
but like week on release two games with
such similar names within a year you CEO
or a CEO to you know like outlaw is
gonna be like three years from now
Seneca Doane cars but like with origins
I never really got sucked into that
story at all I felt like I said like I
really enjoyed the world and the world
was great and I you know loved ancient
Egypt as a kid but by a story just
didn't grab me whereas I found with
Cassandra story immediately like they've
thrown twists at you and curve balls at
you and it's actually like a really
well-written and well plotted out story
and it's just really grabbed me which I
really didn't expect from Assassin's
Creed game
you are my greatest pride remember that
you will bring this family to glory
girl I think the voice acting helps I
like her voice actor so now we did
surrounding cast as well you can tell
they put more attention into even like
the side characters in this game where I
felt an origins at the side quests were
oh this is just a random side quest
where I do don't kill these three things
for me yeah that guy for me get this
specific item from that guy and then
come back and they have that in this
game but they're relegated to like the
bounty board stuff which is sort of like
here's your endless content super
optional so it's easy to like oh I could
just ignore all that and I can only
focus on the major side quest and those
all feel really well written where
they're either funny isn't it doing
something interesting sometimes they're
like multi-layered
really like major choices sometimes so
you'd like come back into the main story
I feel like they've finally figured out
how to make interesting like side
content and make it feel more like
another in content that you actually
want to invest in like Marcus and Phoebe
are two characters that in almost any
other sized inscri game or almost any
other open RPG I'd be so annoyed with
them as these people are always getting
into trouble and solve another problem
and like I don't want to do any of this
and yet somehow they kind of make those
early side quests with the two of them
believable like this would totally
happen you can understand why Cassandra
Alexios is putting up with them yeah
like they're kind of lovable almost no
worries you know this is very nice nice
stupid can you get stop giving him money
he always pays me back after I
threatened him exactly everybody
benefits
furries gets his money I get my interest
and you have work Kefalonia is wonderful
is it not clearly someone on the design
team was like we have to be more Witcher
and there are so many like influences
from that game in Odyssey to the music
that plays whenever you complete the
quest I genuinely thought was which I'm
saying my god yeah
what I think is really great about
assassins is that obviously it manages
to definitely feel like an assassin's
Creed game but it takes and lifts things
from which an even shadow of mordor
shadow of war right in terms of its
gameplay which is a we at least cyclical
thing when you think about it but it
makes it a game that feels inherently
very familiar but because the story is
so much better and so much more
interesting it just feels for me is that
my favorites essence Creed games since
syndicate I mean there hasn't really
been that many but yeah so just be not
origins were you know I think its
origins was them trying something and
Odyssey is them getting ever ever closer
to getting it completely perfectly right
that's not to say the other on issues
but this game yeah you mentioned them
the shadow of war is stuff like the
mercenary stuff that feels I kind of
wish they just almost completely copied
it where they got real close so you have
like these mercenaries that hunt you
down as you get like your GTA 5 star
bounty up yep and it's cool because like
the menu is very it's almost like a it's
a cottage right you know they're all
standing there and there's like shadows
in the back and they have like
weaknesses and strengths and they have
like a little bio yeah but it lacks that
like them actually coming up to you and
being like Oh Andrew because you don't
know how to grow grapes or make wine I'm
a fast learner you grow grapes and they
fine then you get some wine it's that
simple is it you know I can't they just
like fully embrace that aspect to it but
it feels like then testing the waters
with that idea of like I even have yeah
I kind of amazed no one is probably
ripped off the Nemesis system you I know
right and so honestly you like for
Assassin's Creed to rip it off like you
said is this a little cyclical but I
know there's a lot of pieces in Odyssey
that are exactly like that it's like
they've pulled small things from games
and none of them are as good
as what the other game doesn't like the
combat is very Witcher the bounty
hunters is very shot of Mordor the
exploration is very breath of the wild
the romance is trying to be Mass Effect
or Dragon Age and it's like going on so
they're not getting there allow me to
satisfy your hunger I've never been with
a mercenary before very well let's see
what you're made of we have like a
document where we're talking about you
know what we're experiencing is we're
playing all three of us similarly it's
pretty good so the first character you
kind of you can meet oh yeah and you
know you can immediately just go full
flirting and I was hitting on her so I
just I put all my cards on the table I
was like come on let's bone and she was
like oh I'd love to but I have to go get
this thing for my dad she's dying he's
dying
it's like so we can put after that right
yeah and then he get stuff going just
like oh actually I've got another little
menial task I need to do and otherwise
I'll be you know oh well we all appear
and then you finally you know get
together with someone and it just does
the Mass Effect one Oh before we get
serious how about we finally have some
fun I think I can spare a little bit of
time I plan on taking a lot longer than
that
when it comes to thinking about the game
I really enjoy it when I'm playing it I
feel like it could lose the romance
stuff it could also lose so there's this
whole cults thing part of the story and
that's a whole other gameplay mechanic
and then there's the ship stuff which is
another gameplay part which is huge and
then there's the the mercenary stuff and
it just feels like while the rest of it
is like really well paced and I was
actually surprised that I wasn't finding
myself doing over level two things
but I did just feel sometimes it just
gets a bit much with what it gives me
yeah they give you way too much although
somebody dial it back from origins
definitely and and I think some of it
works better than others I think the the
cold stuff I actually really like the
way they implement it it's the menu is
similar to how it is in origins where
it's like here's your kill list but yeah
in origins it was just a list and there
wasn't really much you do with that menu
this you actually are like as we take
down people you get clues about like the
next person that's and that kind of
feeds into the game's exploration system
where they're trying to like make you
the player feel like you haven't seen
how you're like finding locations in
something requests which it feels like a
step in the right direction for making
the game more breadth of the wild like I
just feel like maybe it's because in
oldest substance Creed games you would
have these so it when it came to like
two for example and you're in like Rome
and everything's you go in there are so
many recognizable places that you just
immediately latch on to and you know to
go to like Vatican City or whatever and
you want to like climb to the top of
that whereas it just felt like you had a
purpose to go to those big locations
grows in the later games for example you
just kind of felt like okay the the
world is there I'm not really
interacting with it but now because of
the new mode I feel like I'm actually
exploring it further I'm going oh I need
to go to the valley of the snakes where
as if that was you know in origins I
couldn't tell you the name of any of the
roots right well you actually have to
like look for the clues look at the map
properly and figure out where it is you
have to go and I think there's a great
way of interacting with the world it
makes me feel like I'm more a part of it
the one thing I would say that I also
miss from old Assassin's games is the
parkour stuff so in breath of the wall
dogs you had like stamina which kind of
could limit what you could climb yeah
it's a rest need to think about it more
logically in this I can just set a
waypoint and I can just go straight
there holding down X and I know that I
can climb any mountain clamber across
any tree because that's just the way
that it works now whereas in like old
sanskrit games you have to figure out a
puzzle pathway to get to the top of a
synchronization point where it feels
like that's definitely lesser than focus
on this game it's not really about
traversing or like the challenge of
traversing just more about discovering
by interesting occasions what you think
it's shared it's a shame because like
Lucy said like Assassin's Creed used to
have three cores it was like exploration
stealth and I think it was just combat
or something like that but it's kind of
like the whole exploration combat
expected but it's kind of lost its
Assassin's Creed identity it doesn't
really feel so much feel like an
assassin's Creed game anymore
wait you traverse the world yeah I guess
for me I don't mind that that much
because I've been burnout for a while
like the last one I truly enjoyed was
Black Flag right and then and this one
feels like a true like next generation
Black Flag where my favorite part about
Black Flag was the ship stuff but then
when you were to like dock on to inga
city it would just go into a loading
screen and it's like up now I'm in a
separate little mini assassin screen
town and this one they're taking the
seamless open world of origins and
they're combining it with like the
endless ocean of Black Flag so it's like
no I can at any point I can just hop off
my ship and like you know swim over to
that Island and then it's just massive
island I can explore every inch of it
yeah that feels really impressive
just in terms of scale in a way that not
even Witcher bully does because which
are like still separates its Maps yeah
like four distinct areas like this is
like one massive map that like for the
most part like there's almost no gaming
to it and that just feels impressive
it's mostly just loading between
cutscenes I think yeah one thing I would
say about the combat actually because I
tend always start for stealth as much as
I can and then inevitably I'll mess it
up but what I like about the combat is
that it feels like I can Age Inquisition
combat like you had everything kind of
mapped and stuff and it kind of feels
like that's me but that's not a bad
thing because the way that they're doing
it and the way that you can respect at
any time I just really like because it
makes me feel more adventurous which is
something that olds has Creed you know
they've just kind of lumped you in a
solution was a little bit more freedom
with how you map things it's like if you
hold down the bumper you can do all your
melee type attacks to that and then the
trigger has all of your arrow base the
toxic because they basically change it
from origins for origins there was a
bunch of different bows and yeah this
one is way better words those are
basically all the same you can unlock
which hunter sniper abilities that you
want for it but I don't use too many of
the bow ability so there's just like
four empty slots that I can but skills
into that I'm kind of bummed are you
like I would liken it rather yeah like I
have a bunch of a different assassin
skills because like Lucy I just love to
stealth but I have to keep going back
and forth between like the ability to
rip out a shield and spartan kick and i
would prefer to just have both of them
ready at once
smart kicks real cool now it is you ever
came to do it off a mountain but it's
really good I should use it got us to
find what I need that's it I got the
wrap up beautiful and where it heals as
well man people that hurt it's not easy